Speaker 1: Sometimes, you know when you follow
a story for a while, it's actually rewarding.
It's actually rewarding because you can see the
evolution of lies from people. And that is exactly
what I have for you today. The headline is we have
now learned Republican Congressman Jim Jordan did
talk to Donald Trump on the morning of the Jan.
six Trump riots for at least 10 minutes straight,
just the two of them on the phone. You might
say, Why is that a story? It's a story,
because for a year plus now, Jim Jordan
has been deliberately deceptive about his
conversations with Donald Trump on the day of
the Trump riots. So let's start with the news.
Newly obtained records show Trump and Jim Jordan
spoke at length on the morning of January 6th.
The House Select Committee investigating the
insurrection now has records which provide
details about a phone call Donald Trump made
to Jim Jordan on January 6th. Two sources who
reviewed the call records tell CNN Trump spoke on
the phone at the White House residence with Jordan
for 10 minutes on the morning of Jan. six. Why do
we care about that? We care about that because we
want to have Jim Jordan tell us what was Trump
planning? What was Trump hoping would happen
on that day? And for as long as Jim Jordan says,
Oh, I don't know the I don't know if I spoke to
him before or after. I don't know if I spoke to
him at all. No, I did, but I'm not sure we can.
We have more trouble for to the extent that
we can't prove this conversation took place.
Holding Jim Jordan accountable to get him to
either tell us what Trump said on that day
or to say I'm going to plead the fifth or
whatever the case may be. A key focus of the
committee's investigation has been on the run up
to the insurrection and the myriad ways Trump and
his allies, including those in Congress, spoke to
Trump tried to overturn the election results. The
new details about the morning phone call comes as
the committee is debating whether to move forward
with a subpoena for Jordan after he refused to
voluntarily appear for an interview. So now we
know that he did speak to him on that morning.
Here is the deceiving, constant backed back story
with Jim Jordan. First of all, remember when he
spoke to Olivia Olivia Beavers from Politico,
where he said quote, Look, I definitely spoke to
the president that day. I don't recall. I know
it was more than once. I just don't recall the
times. He was then asked about it by Brett Bayer.
Let's listen to what he had to say then.
Speaker 2: I mean, he's obviously going
to go down a number of different roads about who
knew what, when, who was talking to coordinators
of the protests. Did you talk to the former
president that day? I've talked to the former
president umpteen times thousands. I mean,
I may not have been on January. Countless,
countless times I talked to the president. I
never talk about what we talk about. I just
don't think that's appropriate because like,
I don't talk about what happens in Republican.
Speaker 1: Now, remember Brett Bayer
didn't ask what you talked about,
he said. Did you talk to him on that day? And
Jim Jordan says, I've talked to him many times,
but I don't talk about what we talked about. The
question was, did you talk to him on that day?
Speaker 2: Passes sharp talk to the president
numerous times. I continue to talk to the
president on Jan. six, congressman. Yes. I mean,
I've talked to the president. I've talked to the
president. So I can't remember all the days I've
talked to him, but I've certainly talked to the
president. Yeah. And on that day was, can you
share any of the inside of what he was thinking
about that day? But Brett, the people we need to
come testify are the people who can testify to
the fundamental questions. Why didn't the
United States Capitol, the People's House,
have an appropriate security posture?
Speaker 1: Now what's funny is
the committee has decided Jordan should
testify, but he's refusing to go a day.
Speaker 2: And what have we done? Those
are the people we need to hear from
those. That's information and testimony we need
to get. That's what we should focus on. But I
don't think that Bennie Thompson, the chairman
of this committee, said everything's on the table
until we raise this issue about the speaker's
office is the one who knows what the security
posture and why it was the way it was.
Speaker 1: OK, so he didn't answer.
Shortly thereafter, a couple of weeks
later, he was then interviewed again and
this was on spectrum news. And just as evasive.
Speaker 2: There's some confusion over what you
told Bret there on Fox News on Tuesday night,
so I want to clear it up. First off, yes or no?
Did you speak with President Trump on January six?
Yeah, I mean, I speak. I spoke with the president
last week. I speak with the president all the
time. I spoke with him on January six. I mean,
I talked with President Trump all the time,
and that's that's I don't think that's so here.
Speaker 1: It was no longer tenable to maintain
he didn't speak to Trump on the 6th. So here,
he conceded. I did speak to him on the 6th.
Speaker 2: Unusual, I would expect members
of Congress to talk with the president of
the United States when they're trying to
get done the things they told the voters in
their district to do. I'm actually kind of
amazed sometimes that people keep asking this,
but of course I talk to the president Typekit.
Speaker 1: Well, the reason people keep
asking is because he was not directly saying,
I spoke to him on January 6th.
Speaker 2: I said I talked with him last week
on January six. Did you speak with him before,
during or after the Capitol was attacked?
I have to go. I I spoke with him that day after,
I think, after. I don't know if I spoke with him
in the morning or not, and I just don't know.
Speaker 1: He just doesn't know now. It is
completely implausible that even if you bought at
the time the first time he was asked, Did you talk
to him that day? Let's give him the benefit of the
doubt, because this is how you have to think about
how absurd this was. Imagine that Jim Jordan
really speaks to Trump every day and asked a
month later, Did you speak to him on January six?
Imagine he genuinely doesn't remember. I don't
believe that for a second. I believe you remember.
But let's give him the benefit of the doubt
once it is asked on Fox News. And the answer is
so obviously deceptive. There is no way in hell
that among his, you know, plentiful staff, no one
comes to him and says, Sir, you spoke to Trump
twice on January six, including before the right.
So now, you know, there is no way after that he
doesn't remember. And here he is still saying,
I just don't know, was it before or after now?
Of course, on a day that's that momentous. It's
sort of like, if I think, back to nine eleven,
right? I remember where I was. And I can tell
you with certainty what happened after or before.
Like, if you say to me, did you work on the on
911? I remember that, yes, I worked on 911. I
remember talking to my colleagues about what
was going on. And so if you say and were you
at work at all before the events took place,
I can say, of course not. There was no period
that day where while at work, I learned about
what was happening my entire day at work on 911,
I was in high school at the time was after the
events took place. When I went in, it was like,
Are we even staying open? This is crazy, etc..
There's no doubt about it because it's a notable
event. And so this idea that, oh yeah, bill,
did you speak to him at all before the riot or
obviously, the conversation would either
be what is Trump expecting to happen
or what is Trump react? How is Trump
reacting to what is happening? It's just
completely implausible that he doesn't remember.
Speaker 2: I have to go back. I mean, I don't
I don't, I don't. I don't know that when when
those conversations happened, give me a buddy.
But what I know is I spoke about the time. But
but Taylor, the key here is the people we need
to speak to, the people we need to talk to
are the ones who can answer the question
Why wasn't there a better security presence?
Speaker 1: Now, Jim, you're one of the people
that we actually need to be talking to. So obvious
liar, obvious liar. And now, I mean, listen,
it took what? It took 14 months, 14 months. We've
been following this. Jim Jordan spoke to Trump
that morning before the riot. And so Jim Jordan
could tell us, did Trump say anything about hoping
that there was violence? Did Trump say anything
about what he was expecting Mike Pence to do? This
is the guy that we should be talking to, and they
tried to talk to him and he's refusing to appear.